كان لدى شخصين في المملكة المتحدة
تاريخ من ردود الفعل التحسسية الشديدة ردود
فعل تحسسية تجاه اللقاح
الآن
وهذا ليس بالضرورة سببًا للقلق
ولا يجب أن يقلق الناس بشأنه
ولكن
ملايين الأمريكيين يعانون من جميع أنواع
الحساسية بدءًا من
غبار اللوز وحتى  من القطط إلى البنسلين
فقط لكونه تمرينًا إعلاميًا
هنا أي الحساسية
يجب ولا يجب أن تمنع الأمريكيين
من أخذ اللقاح في هذه المرحلة
جيك هذا مهم جدًا لدينا
الكثير من الأسئلة وكما يمكنك أن تتخيل
هذا هو سبب
قيامنا بخطنا  من خلال مراجعة
البيانات ، لذا فإن
شروط الاستخدام لدينا هي ما نسميه بها على
وجه التحديد تنص على أنه إذا كان لديك
حساسية من أي مكون من لقاح pfizer
bioentech ،
فلا يجب أن تحصل عليه ، كما قلنا
أن تلك
البيئات التي يوجد بها
اللقاح  سيتم إعطاؤك
هناك يجب أن تكون الأدوات المتاحة
لإدارة الأدوية
أه والدعم في حالة إصابة شخص ما
برد فعل تحسسي شديد ورد فعل تحسسي لديك
النقطة التي تم أخذها جيدًا ،
لا نعتقد أن هذه
مشكلة متكررة للغاية ستظهر ولكننا نريد أن
نكون حذرين لأن
سلامة المنتجات الطبية في اللقاحات هي على رأس أولوياتنا
وأين يمكن للأشخاص
العثور على قائمة المكونات للحاجة
إلى أفضل
كلمة في اللقاح الحيوي والتقني لشركة فايزر
حتى يعرفوا
أه ما الذي تم استيفاءه وما هي المكونات
حتى إذا كانوا يعانون من الحساسية تجاهها ،
فلا ينبغي لهم تناولها ،
لذا أود تشجيع المرضى
على الذهاب إلى
وضع العلامات على المنتج أيضًا  نظرًا
لشروط الاستخدام وخطاب
التفويض ، فقد كنا شفافين جدًا في
ذلك وقمنا بنشره على موقعنا على الويب